i was very anxiety ridden i was
i was really in knots inside and
um i really needed that tool
i ran six miles every day i did
everything i could
to release anxiety because i grew up
with an incredible amount of anxiety
tied up inside of me and i really had to
focus for
a while when i was younger to get rid of
that
to get that out of my life it's amazing
that at a at a young age you can
actually understand you knew what was
happening to you right you knew that
there's something going on that's just
that i have to i have to try and do
everything i can to control it
absolutely i was drinking too much i was
doing drugs i was smoking a pack a day
and i was having seizures i i had
something called psychomotor epilepsy
that started when i was about 14.
and i'd have fits and they did all kinds
of brain scans and they said you do not
have epilepsy
but you have a a psychological condition
called long-term anxiety
and it comes from growing up in a
situation of such anxiety such tension
that your your your nervous system has
this valve
that you've developed and it's
giving you these seizures and um
it was really dramatic i mean i once
flew off my bicycle
i once fell off a roof
i would have these seizures and um so i
had to do everything i could to
alleviate anxiety would you think
obviously i mean obviously i don't say
obviously but do you think it stemmed
from
maybe just upbringing and being around
dysfunction at all oh god
it was all about that my father was a
i was a fall down drunk and he was a
mean drunk and he was a
old world very imperious
man he was a child of immigrants he grew
up in
um hell's kitchen in new york he was an
entirely self-made man he was
he was a street kid in new york and
um a really tough one and he was born in
so it was like having a grandfather you
know he was much older
and um he was very old world
old irish and um everything had to be
very formal we were little we had to
call them serves stuff like that
and the fights in our house growing up
were just legendary it was like growing
up in
a long day's journey and tonight i mean
it was just this
irish drunk crazy
fighting clan
all my elder siblings were fighting with
my father
and my mother was very very much like
mary tyrone in long day's journey she
was very passive
she was very loving but just beaten down
by this man
that she'd been married to and um
everyone get out of that house as soon
as they could
all my older siblings who were much
older
and um so at the time i got to be around
14 i was there alone and it was
insane in that house i mean that day my
father was drunk
every day and my mother started drinking
heavily
and i ended up moving out of that house
when i was 16 and moved in with a
friend's family
just so i could finish high school and
they let you
stay there you could not live there it
was it was it was
it was the police were there all the
time it was crazy
it was crazy wow so so it was it was
screaming it was yelling it was physical
it was alcohol it was everything
everything my god you know it's kind of
a classic you know it's not that unusual
it is like well hang on a second
fortunately it's not that unusual well i
i talk about some dysfunction that i had
people talk about their dysfunctions but
then it always
you always hear someone else's story and
you're like that was fine
yeah i mean listen to kevin i mean kevin
really had it bad i feel better
i don't feel better i feel horrible for
you but i just like it
you know i talk about this all the time
but it is
you you see you have i'm sure you have
friends or people that like oh i
actually grew up in a normal
environment my parents didn't drink they
were kind they were loving they're still
together
and you and don't you i sort of i i mean
i envy that oh
i am in awe of families like that like
right
like that you know who's like that who
dietrich vader and you could tell
i love that family he and his wife and
these two kids
they adore each other they
are happy together you go into that
house and it's just
functioning loving warm
and you sit there and you think this
really does exist
you know i never saw that growing up so
i love that family they were wonderful